une augmentation considérable du nombre
de cases ce sont les mots employés par
le gouvernement espagnol
435 à de kobe de 19% mais l'habitant
dans les hôpitaux le taux d'occupation
en soin intensif de patients atteints du
coronavirus est passé à 26 %
alors le gouvernement explique qu'il
s'attendait à de tels chiffres
après les déplacements et rassemblement
des espagnols durant les fêtes de fin
d'année il a tenu à expliquer que la
hausse n'est pas dû aux variants
britannique a paru dans le pays fin
décembre alors la situation n'est pas
encourageante les prochaines semaines
vont être compliqués les hôpitaux seront
sous pression et l'objectif est d'éviter
leur saturation
alors le gouvernement demande à ses
habitants de faire très attention de
fournir un effort supplémentaire et
malgré tout l'espagne écarte la
possibilité d'un nouveau confinement
je vous propose d'écouter fernando
simone du ministère de la santé
cet incident violent nous sommes dans
une situation très en-deça de la
première vague est très similaire à ce
qu'il s'est passé lors de la seconde
vague durant la deuxième vague
nous n'avons pas eu besoin de faire un
confinement et nous avons réussi à
contrôler et à avoir un impact moins
important sur la société et l'économie
je pense que si nous sommes dans une
situation où si nous sommes tous
conscients de ce que nous devons faire
et si nous le faisons que nous sommes
vraiment solidaires les uns les autres
et que les institutions font aussi ce
qu'elles doivent faire
je pense que nous pourrons ouvrir je
pense que nous pourrons réussir à
contrôler l'épidémie sont nécessité d'un
nouveau confinement
les experts prévoient la fin du tunnel
pour le début de l'été et en attendant
l'espagne active sa vaccination 50% des
doses reçues ont été administrés et le
pays compte accélérer la cadence pour
les prochaines semaines